au pouvoir depuis 14 mois françois
legault adhère toujours à la même
philosophie offrir aux québécois un
gouvernement près des gens et surtout
respecter ses promesses
dans cet esprit il a fait adopter
rapidement plusieurs projets de loi
comme ceux sur le cannabis le taux
unique de taxation scolaire les
maternelles quatre ans la laïcité de
l'état et l'immigration
un empressement qui a provoqué un tollé
en immigration par exemple le
gouvernement voulait éliminer 18 mille
dossiers de nouveaux arrivants en
attente de traitement et réformer les
critères d'admission des étudiants
étrangers
la grogne est telle qu'il a dû reculer
sur chacune de ces mesures
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir le
gouvernement caquistes à profiter d'une
économie solide qui lui a permis
d'enregistrer des surplus de près d'un
milliard et demi de dollars pour 2019
2020 avant le versements au fonds des
générations
ce sont principalement les familles avec
enfants et les aînés qui en ont
bénéficié
il devra se montrer prudent face au
spectre d'un ralentissement économique
françois legault encore bien du pain sur
la planche wiki le augmenter le niveau
de richesse des québécois il doit
négocier de nouveaux contrats de travail
avec ses milliers de fonctionnaires
faire face à des pénuries de
main-d'oeuvre sérieuse en plus de
présenter dans quelques mois un plan
environnemental
françois legault bonjour bonjour
monsieur thibault merci d'être avec nous
ça fait 4 ça fait quatre cents jours un
peu plus de 400 jours que vous êtes au
pouvoir maintenant vous avez choisi
d'aller très très vite dans un paquet
dossier en immigration et laïcité que le
cannabis entre autres est ce que vous
regrettez parfois de pas avoir pris plus
de temps non je pense que une des choses
qui est apprécié par les québécois ce
qu'on ne tenu nos promesses souvent les
partis politiques se présentent font des
promesses peu après on trouve toutes
sortes d'excusés pour pour remplir leurs
promesses
donc moi c'est important de retourner de
l'argent notre portefeuille on l'avait
promis la loi 21 l'immigration et la
question des cinq religions l'avait
promis ses tapas un sa brosse un petit
peu mais en même temps en même temps les
gens quand ils m'arrêtent dans la rue
disent merci monsieur legault on se sent
fier
on sent qu'on a un gouvernement qui
respecte ses promesses donc il ya
peut-être le côté de dire qu'à trop fait
des changements ça bouscule un peu mais
je pense quand la majorité des gens sont
satisfaits
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
maintenant vous presser leur faisant
vite comme ça ça a pas un peu miné le
travail de préparation vous auriez dû y
mettre à certains égards ce qui en a eu
des cafouillages j'en ai eu des mamans
ourses depuis dix ans mais je dirais que
dans la grande majorité des dossiers les
gens sont satisfaits
d'abord qu'on ait fait des changements
en éducation en santé qu'on ait réduit
les taxes cola qu'on ait réduit les
tarifs de garderie qu'on a augmenté à
l'occasion familiale les jeunes quand
ils regardent leur quotidien il semble
qu'il ya eu des changements qui ça
répondait ce qu'on avait promis donc bon
l'immigration et les cafouillages en
immigration
mais en même plus vite les gens
m'arrêtent souhaite miser sur le gouffre
avait raison les migrants qui ont choisi
doivent davantage répondre aux besoins
des entreprises
oui on a dit on rachète des dossiers
parce que ces dossiers ils ont été
choisis premier arrivé premier servi
nous on aime mieux
choisie est vraiment selon les besoins
des entreprises
donc il y en a qui ont pas aimé ça mais
je dirais encore les gens malgré les
essais erreurs parfois sont satisfaits
des résultats
donc c'était la moyenne que vous
l'événement moi je pense à la moyen
assez comme en affaires c'est comme en
sport sa moyenne au bâton puis notre
moyenne au bâton est très bas on montre
souvent du doigt
sinon j'allais barrette parce que il est
à l'origine de certains de ces
cafouillages la sks que son travail de
leader parlementaire qui lui prend
beaucoup de temps lui laisse
suffisamment d'espacé pour se consacrer
autant qu'ils devraient le faire à
certains des dossiers montrent un jeune
talentueux travaillant faut être capable
dû donner des défis pour le motiver et y
en a des défis il y en a beaucoup mais
si on prend par exemple la loi 21 mois
j'ai passé une bonne partie de l'été
passé à me faire dire et puis il appelle
le petit simon jallet barrette monsieur
legault votre petit simon j'en ai marre
d'être là bravo le dit luc continuer
donc je pense que les voiliers les
cafouillages vous avec lui vous les
voyez les p'tits mômes à ce que vous
avez simon en a trop qui monte en fait
trop tu vas trouver tenons en sport je
pense que dans le dossier des étudiants
c'est délicat de dire on va choisir les
étudiants dans les domaines où on a des
besoins
ces délits qu on quand on fait des
changements vu deux grosses erreurs par
contre là dessus avait déjà fait des
programmes de formation qui existait
plus il ya des trucs payante et on
pourrait il prendre un par un le mais le
fameux programme sciences domestique
c'est c'est toute la formation en
consommation des gens aujourd'hui le
qu'on consomme de façon
qui respecte notre santé c'est dans
science domestique évidemment il y en a
qui en ont profité pour se moquer mais
encore une fois moi je pense que la
moyenne au bâton est très bas vous avez
et vous l'avez dit dans le passé vous
avez privilégié un style de gestion pour
le gouvernement qui s'apparente un peu
un style de gestion du secteur privé de
ce que vous faisiez à l'époque quand
vous étiez chez transat par exemple
est-ce que vous un an plus tard
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que ce
style de gestion là il s'applique bien
au modèle étatique compte tenu de ce que
fait un gouvernement par rapport à
l'entreprise une entreprise privée c'est
l'aube fait des profits donc on
surveille le profit dans le prochain
trimestre le gouvernement il faut rendre
des services de façon efficace
donc il faut que les enfants qui ont des
besoins à l'école et un orthophoniste
que les personnes qui sont à l'hôpital
servez donc une question quand même
d'efficacité c'est pas moins important d
efficace dans la façon de donner les
services que d'être efficaces fois des
profits donc l'objectif final est pas de
même mais les moyens l'efficacité il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire même encore
aujourd'hui une machine lourde le
gouvernement les systèmes d'information
sont pas à jour donc d'avoir un petit
peu privé dans la proche pour être plus
efficace je pense ça fait juste du bien
j'aimerais qu'on vient sur la laïcité
parce que vous l'avez abordé derrière la
loi 21
quand vous avez adopté cela vous l'avez
fait vite parce que c'est ce que les
québécois voulaient avez vous dit est-ce
que vous vous attendiez à ce moment
alain hot lixx a soulevé au québec mais
août alix a soulevé que ça soulève
encore au en ontario au manitoba dans le
reste du pays
parce que vous êtes critiqué votre
gouvernement est critiqué par les autres
provinces pour sackey d'abord faut
revenir à la base on a dit on interdit
les signes religieux seulement pour les
policiers les gardiens de prison les
juges et les enseignants pour les
enfants donc ça inclut pas les cégeps
les universités cela ça existe en france
en allemagne en suisse en belgique dans
plusieurs pays
est-ce que les ce que brahim palestre le
premier ministre du manitoba va aller
dire aux allemands ou aux français ce
qui nous dit est bien passé votre voisin
voisins immédiats vous êtes gars d'à
côté et à l'intérieur de la fédération
canadienne ya des gens il ya des
administrations un seuil qui regarde ce
qu'ils disent c'est un peu raciste à la
limite ses comportements
j'espère qu'ils disent pour sa part
c'est pas du tout raciste
je pense qu'on a des sentiments mais en
même temps est-ce que les allemands son
récit c'est ce que les français sont
racistes c'est ce que les belges sont
racistes
moi je pense qu'il faut être prudent
c'est une loi qui est très modérée et
une loi aussi qu'ils évitent les
extrêmes qui évite justement les
détournements plus racistes comme on a
vu dans d'autres pays mais vous saviez
que ce serait compliqué parce que vous
avez inclut la clause dérogatoire
d'autres mais je peux le premier robert
bourassa aux jo à utiliser la clause
dérogatoire la clause dérogatoire est là
pour protéger notre nation la nation
québécoise sur une langue qui a des
valeurs que sa culture puisqu'elle doit
défendre son identité que la laïcité au
québec quand on connaît la petite
histoire du québec là où les religions
étaient très présents dans notre système
d'éducation de santé mais les gens
souhaitent qu'une séparation entre
l'état et les religions
donc moi je pense qu'on est exactement
là où sont la grande majorité des
québécois
je vous ai entendu souvent évoqué la
fierté de droit et les coins un peu
comme on l'entendait des années soixante
dix les années 80 aussi est-ce qu'on en
est encore là dans discours politique
est ce que c'est encore ça qu'il faut
évoquer au québec
oui absolument moi je pense que les
québécois
bon d'abord on a une langue qui sera
toujours vulnérable en amérique du nord
le français on a une culture nous ont
été laissés par nos ancêtres
on a un certain nombre de valeurs
l'égalité hommes femmes par exemple
c'est très important au québec mais la
laïcité être capable d'être
ouvert mais en même temps de protéger ce
qu'on est
moi je pense que les québec les
québécois se reconnaissent dans cette
danse nationalisme moi je pense entre
autre les jeunes ne s'intéressent plus
aux souverainistes à la souveraineté du
québec
mais quand on leur demande est ce que
c'est important de protéger votre clan
nouveau valeur votre culture la majorité
disent que cette fierté là quand est ce
que les québécois l'ont perdue des
primes aux cadres est ce que ça ça
descendu mais on a eu les retrouver on a
eu quinze années de gouvernement libéral
à part une petite parenthèse de 18 mois
pense que tous les analystes vont dire
et jean charest effet les brouillards
n'était pas aussi nationaliste par
exemple qu'un jean lesage pour un robert
bourassa et je pense ça s'est perdu
pendant ses 15 ans le fait de ne pas
être fier de ce qu'ont et les québécois
de défendre notre nation puis c'est
incroyable le nombre de québécois rrq
marek m'a dit monsieur legault vous nous
avez redonné notre fierté des québécois
puissent pour ça on va continuer ce côté
de la lame du côté de la culture a posé
des gestes parce que si on veut être
capable au québec de d'avoir un projet
économique mais il faut d'abord qu'on
soit une famille la famille best autour
de l'identité la famille famille c'est
l'éducation l'éducation ce sont les
maternelles quatre heures dans votre cas
c'est un projet qui vous tenait à coeur
et on dirait que les québécois ont de la
difficulté à vous suivre là dedans il y
avait un sondage cette semaine qui
disait que 45 % des québécois étaient
satisfaits de cette approche est ce que
vous avez pas réussi simplement à leur
expliquer ce que c'est un travail de
pédagogie qui manque dans ce dossier bon
d'abord mouche pas satisfaits des taux
de diplomation au québec on a des moins
bons taux de diplomation québec dans les
autres provinces
ouais mais ça fait comme ça commence on
commence on l'a qu'est ce que les
spécialistes nous disent fois j'ai
plutôt si on aide un enfant de moins de
6 ans ça va être dix fois plus efficace
que si on atteint après six ans et on y
descend de la petite enfance sont là
pour selon qu'on a des 100 d'abstention
des garderies
who you des techniciens de garde qui
font un travail extraordinaire
nous ce qu'on dit c'est quand un enfant
a des difficultés puis à peu près un
enfant sur quatre aujourd'hui nos mêmes
27 % des enfants qui ont des difficultés
d'apprentissage sont la voie à l'école
avec un enseignant et une formation
universitaire dans les écoles ya des
orthophonistes orthopédagogue pour aider
ces enfants là on multiplie ses chances
pour que l'enfant réussissent donc ça
vaut la peine
puis on n'est pas seul en ontario ça
commence à 4 1 en france ça commence à
trop leurs matériaux ils ont pas les
garderies est ok bien une différence
entre les garderies aps l'école il faut
comprendre ça c'est vous qui il ya une
déconnexion parce que vous avez aussi
puisque les gens comprennent il ya une
grosse pression les gens qui travaillent
la garderie se disent on va nous voler
des enfants des clients alors que nous
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on dit on offre
aux gens de choix vous pouvez continuer
d'aller à la garderie mais si par
exemple vous avez un enfant qui a des
difficultés d'apprentissage mais nous on
pense qu'à l'école avec des enseignants
avec des spécialistes
on va multiplier les chances pour que
cet enfant leur réussissent sur le gong
un débat de la campagne vous avez dit je
mets ma job dont j'ai là dessus elle est
où la ligne pour vous à quel moment vous
êtes ok je démissionne oh ben écoutez
moi lors ce en crève le coeur de voir un
enfant qui a des difficultés
d'apprentissage qui on donne pas les
services qui se noie on attend du beau
travail sinon mais pour moi lors
investir en éducation autant pour le
dépistage que pour donner des services à
4 ans dans des écoles c'est non
négociable pour moi c'est une des
raisons principales pour quoi je tends
politiques pour qu'ils aient plus
d'enfants qui réussissent puis faut agir
tôt puis on veut investir c'est un bon
investissement allait réussir pour voir
yves ses puits dans trois ans en 2022
je vous parie que tous les partis
politiques vont être d'accord avec nous
françois legault on a parlé d'éducation
de parler de laïcité par monde santé
william lui ni promesse que j'avais
faite aux québécois c'est de réduire le
temps d'attenté dans les urgences reste
90 minutes
les chiffres publiés par le ministère de
la santé disent que ça augmenter de
votre arrivée au pouvoir de six minutes
depuis un an on attend maintenant 227
ella jeudi l'institut canadien
d'information avait des chiffres qui dit
que la médiane au québec c'était 4,6 1
et que dans 90 % des visites à l'urgence
les gens sont là pendant plus de 18
heures on est loin du 4 avril
je voudrais échoué là dessus non pas du
tout c'est pas un problème qui est
facile à régler mais la solution passe
par ce qui se passe dans l'hôpital ça se
passe par ce qu'on appelle la première
ligne actuellement 50% des patients dans
nos urgences devraient pas être dans les
urgences ce sont des problèmes mineurs
étaient complices 3e
là on a renégocié du salaire des
médecins spécialistes le dossier sur
lequel on travaille de façon intensive
actuellement c'est de renégocier
l'entente avec les médecins de famille
pour qu'elle vraie prise en charge pour
qu'un québécois qui est malade soit
capable de voir rapidement son médecin
de famille ou un autre médecin dans le
groupe de médecine de famille est
actuellement la même les québécois qui
ont un médecin de famille sont pas
capables de le voir quand ils sont
malades donc vos engorger les urgences
donc faut vraiment une nouvelle entente
un nouveau mode de rémunération avec les
médecins de famille de les payer par
patient
toutes les payer par à mai mais tout le
monde dit qu'ils consomment moins mais
on n'a jamais réussi à renégocier
l'entente mais tout le monde dit tout le
temps on va réduire les temps d'attentes
on va trouver des médecins de famille
pour tout le monde pourquoi vous vous
allez y et parce qu'on va tenir loppsi
si nécessaire il y aura une loi spéciale
mais on veut revoir l'entente que les
médecins de famille ça peut être bon
sain que des médecins de famille par
exemple travaillent quatre ou cinq jours
par semaine et laisse les patients
orphelins une le soir la fin de semaine
les laisse à l'urgence des hôpitaux
donc il faut que les médecins le groupe
de médecine de famille qui doit donner
le coeur de notre système de santé
c'est une dizaine de médecins
ce partage les plages horaires sur sept
jours et qui se laissent des périodes
ouvertes pour les imprévus
puis voit les patients dans leurs
bureaux là dans leur clsc ou leur bureau
privé et non pas urgent dans votre tête
ça peut passer par un autre spécial vous
vous donner jusqu'à qu'un bain 2020 ça
va se passer le même je dirais au début
2020 très important de revoir
l'organisation une question de
responsabiliser médecins de famille peut
pas dire aux québécois quand vous êtes
malade
allez vous en à l'hôpital est-ce que
vous réitérer votre promesse
un résultat dont le taux d'atteinte à 90
musulman absolument
puis la seule façon qu'on voyait arriver
c'est en sortant une grande partie des
patients des urgences parce qu'ils n'ont
pas d'affaires l'autre sont des
problèmes léger lorsqu'on appelle les p4
et p5 on va pouvoir avoir des urgences
où on est capable de voir les gens à
l'intérieur 90 minutes on a promis ça
pour le mandat ça va se faire sur le
mandat à lons d'économie men vous nagez
dans les surplus de vous vous avez quand
même une situation financière
le québec une situation financière plus
qu'enviable quand on la combat la
compare à celle d'autres d'autres
provinces
vous avez favorisé les aînés vous avez
favorisé les familles aiguisant enfants
qui sont les prochains jours d'abord
c'est important de le répéter là il y
avait des surplus l'année dernière l'on
les autres distribués
on a réduit les taxes scolaires on a
réduit les tarifs de garderie
on a augmenté de façon très importante
les allocations familiales donc les
surplus quéven et dernières vont
disparaître dans les prochaines années
donc c'est important c'est une promesse
importante remette l'argent dans le
portefeuille des québécois
c'est ce qu'on a fait maintenant on va
gérer avec prudence avec efficacité le
budget qu'on a pour les trois années
qu'il est je vous entendre sur
l'environnement parce que vous avez vous
mois et demi
qu'il y avait peut-être il y aurait eu
lieu de bonifier votre facture à la
campagne vous avez promis un plan vert
en 2020 on va surveiller évidemment je
vais vous entendre surtout sur des
projets comme gnl à saguenay troisième
ya québec
ok vous attendez le bape là dessus vous
engagez vous à vous conformer aux
conclusions que le bureau d'audiences
publiques en environnement va vous
servir car ce sera d'abord là je peux
vous dire que même moi personnellement
je parle beaucoup d'heures dans une
semaine à préparer ce plan qui va être
déposée au début de l'année 2020 nous
jeter un groupe pragmatique d'un
comptable faut que ça balance faut qu'on
atteigne nos objectifs de réduction de
grs là où on a beaucoup de travail à
face dans les transports quand on
regarde depuis 1990 on ait réussi à
résoudre nos grc l'europe partout sauf
dans les transports sont promesses et
les crises l'édification des trouées
mais là on a des projets qui avancent
très vite un très mauvais dans l'est de
montréal
un tramway à québec deux traits moins
sur la rive sud de montréal
un trait - à laval un très mauvais en
outaouais
on est en train de travailler sur un
système d'autobus électriques de camions
électriques donc la partie transport là
ça va être une partie importante de
notre plan pour atteindre nos objectifs
mais on va y arriver wazemmes bien
qu'ils y fait rien pour réduire les ges
que là vous me parlez deux dossiers le
troisième ligne et le québec ces grains
tchadien appalaches
c'est une grande région y ont le droit
d'avoir un lien efficace vers québec
donc le troisième ligne et il faut
continuer d'avoir des autos on va
vouloir ça soit des autos électriques
on peut pas avoir du transport en commun
partout au québec le québec ces grains
des régions sont moins densifier
maintenant gnl gnl d'abord c'est un
projet le projet ce qui est prévu cette
prendre du gaz qui vient de l'ouest
canadien
oui qui amène dgs additionnel avec près
de 9 millions la paire québécoise
liquéfié à saguenay
puis d'envoyer par bateau en allemagne
d'un pays en europe où on réduit ray
de 27 millions de tonnes par année les
gs en remplaçant du pétrole du mazout
donc pour la planète parce qu' on est
tous sur la même planète
s'il n'y a pas de réduction de ges on
touche pas ça le bac vous dis non
vous faites que le bape pour nous dit
voici les impacts sur les gs ce qui est
important c'est qu'ils aient un impact
pour réduire au total les gs sur la
planète la semaine prochaine vous allez
rencontrer vos homologues des autres
provinces
oui quel rôle vous jouez vous comme
premier ministre québécois sur
l'échiquier politique canadien mène mais
j'ai une bonne relation se peut avec doc
word on se parle régulièrement
évidemment que le québec et l'ontario
ensemble donc présente une majorité des
canadiens on est tous les deux très axé
sur l'économie
donc on souhaite entre autres revoir
l'entente avec les américains pour le
buy america act qu'on puisse continuer à
exporter nos produits aux états unis on
veut tous les deux avoir un pourcentage
plus d'immigration économique d'oxford
et moi donc sur plusieurs dossiers on
voudrait qui est juste une évaluation
environnementale 7 par les provinces et
non par le gouvernement fédéral en plus
donc donner plus d'autonomie aux
provinces de moi puis d'oxford on
s'entend très bien là dessus puis sur
l'autonomie je dirais son maître côté le
pétrole
jason kenny puis scott mode la
saskatchewan sont très d'accord monsieur
organe aussi accro aux britanniques donc
de décentraliser canada il ya comme un
beau consensus chez les premiers
ministres des provinces
avez vous l'impression que vous êtes en
position de force par rapport avec rudy
lui étant aussi aux minoritaires bah
écoutez c'est ce que est anémique
monsieur trudeau temps position
minoritaire
ces liens sont pas nécessairement facile
avec loup s il ya besoin de l'ontario
pillet du québec
puis nous on s'entend pas il faut
prioriser l'économie donc vous avez
l'impression que vous avez le gros bout
du bâton un peu là dessus ben
je vous donne un exemple nous on
voudrait en pourcentage le plus
d'immigration économique moins
d'immigration non économiques vont quand
même se trouve monsieur trudeau pu nous
refusez ça aux premiers ministres des
provinces dont on est tous d'accord mais
vous avez l'impression du jeu green
position de force de vie bas une
position de force écouter ce trudeau
vaut prendre la décision à la fin mais
on voudrait par exemple que les
transferts que ça soit en santé que ce
soit dans les infrastructures que ça
soit fait aux provinces en condition
donc ça soit être province choisissent
les projets bon ce trudov on est obligé
de nous entendre parce qu'on parle d'eux
mêmes voix sur cette décentralisation
deux dernières questions j'aimerais et
je vous ai jamais entendu là-dessus
c'est qui votre modèle de premier
ministre québécois a écouté pour être
proche du peuple
c'est rené lévesque même si j'ai un jour
fait de la politique c'était parce que
rené lévesque redonner cette fierté aux
québécois moi si j'ai un souhait c'est
d'avoir été capable pendant mes années
de rang des québécois encore plus fier
donc rené lévesque puis bon lucien
bouchard aussi lucien bouchard avait
beaucoup de leadership
je les ai vus autour de la table avec
les ministres être capable de donner une
direction puis dire à tout le monde on
s'envole en direction ono dont rené
lévesque lucien bouchard ce2 beaux
modèles de deux modèles de mode est
souverainiste est ce que monsieur
bouchard encore souverainiste pourrait
lui poser la question
l epa disons nationaliste parce que mais
monsieur lévesque pris le beau risque
canadien faut suivre
où sont les québécois dont deux beaux
modèles nationalistes le québec d'abord
qu'est-ce que vous avez un prix dans la
dernier
année dans votre job dans ce post qui ce
qu'est ce que vous avez retenu de cette
première année au pouvoir
c'est un peu ce que j'avais vécu quand
j'étais président d'air transat que pour
avoir du succès il faut que toute
l'équipe du succès donc faut motiver
tout le monde faut être capable
s'assurer que tout le monde travaille
bien qui épate chicana les internes
c'est ça le mont grands défis comme
leader c'est de s'assurer que les 26 mai
nice les 75 députés travaillent ensemble
sur quelques priorités parce que c'est
illimité les priorités vont encore du
fun oui oui j'ai beaucoup de travail
j'ai beaucoup de plaisir
puis je dis ça les députés les ministres
sense comme une belle famille et on dit
plaisait j'ai dit plaisait je tolère pas
quelqu'un parle contre quelqu'un d'autre
donc on a du plaisir au travail fort
mais on a du plaisir j'ai du plaisir
puis j'aime les québécois aussi j'aime
seul à être capable d'être au service
des québécois françois legault merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur
thibault